[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si je suis ici ce soir au milieu de son
rouge
c'est d'abord parce que je me suis
beaucoup plus en paix
j'ai planté ma première start-up la
deuxième aussi la 3e pas encore mais bon
ça devrait pas tarder nous associer flip
et je vous dire quand on met la clé sous
la porte d'une boîte sait jamais une
épreuve très agréable mais en
entrepreneuriat
c'est normal c'est classique c'est même
presque souhaitable donc si je suis ici
c'est pas pour vous partager comment
j'ai fait pour surmonter mes échecs
comment ces échecs m'ont rendu vraiment
plus fort pas que j'en sois pas persuadé
c'est très vrai mais je préférerais
aujourd'hui partager avec vous
super pouvoirs que j'ai acquis en
plantant mais boîte et on est dans
d'autres personnes à faire mieux que moi
ou pas
ses super pouvoirs c'est celui de savoir
reconnaître un vrai problème on vous
avait mise à niveau super pouvoirs c'est
pas top j'aurais préféré la
téléportation il bon ben moi aussi
mais c'est pas vous donner un petit peu
de contexte
quand on se lancent dans
l'entrepreunariat aujourd'hui beaucoup
de gens vous disent qu'il faut fail fast
for fun il faut se planter vite il faut
se planter souvent la théorie derrière
ça c'est que c'est très très difficile
de trouver la bonne idée du premier coup
et donc qu'il faut aller le plus tôt
possible se confronter à son marché pour
apprendre ajuster le tir changer
complètement de direction s'il faut est
retourné au contact du marché et c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'itération
quand j'ai monté ma boîte
j'ai essayé d'apprendre d'utiliser cette
approche on voulait lancer une
plateforme qui permettait à n'importe
qui de découvrir de nouvelles choses sur
le web pourquoi parce que les
algorithmes de recommandation ont
tendance à filtrer à ce convoi pour nous
montrer plus de choses similaires à ce
qui nous intéresse déjà est très
difficile d'aller au delà de ces bulles
de filtres
belfast on s'est lancé très vite dans le
produit dans le prototypage en effet des
landing pages des mvp du quick and dirty
enfin tous les buzz word de
l'entrepreneuriat tellement berti
d'ailleurs qu'on a dû appeler nos
cinquante premiers utilisateurs pour
leur expliquer où il fallait cliquer sur
l'interface est plus on a eu une
centaine de 100 500 mille utilisateurs à
chaque fois on essayait de vraiment
comprendre ce qui les intéressait dans
la dans la plateforme on a changé
complètement d' approche pour une
deuxième version
et puis on s'est rendu compte de quelque
chose
c'est que même nos utilisateurs les plus
fidèles
revenait de moins en moins souvent sur
la plate forme voire plus du tout
et quand on leur demandait pourquoi nous
disait ah non mais c'est super c'est
super intéressant c'est fun je trouve du
contenu que je trouve vraiment pas autre
part mais
je préfèrerais qu'on reste amis quoi
en fait ils on n'est juste pas besoin
et je me suis rendu compte que on peut
il tirer longtemps en fait dans le vide
si le point de départ n'est pas bon
et l'inconvénient c'est quand on dit
fait elle face fait l'ofen un
entrepreneur bas des douanes un peu de
chercher ce bon point de départ
dès le début parce que on se dit qu'on
va tomber dessus par un peu par hasard
où il va nous tomber dessus par la magie
de l'itération donc pour résoudre ça
pour corriger ça ce que la plupart des
entrepreneurs s'accordent à dire c'est
que finalement l'idée n'a pas de valeur
intrinsèque ce qu'il faut c'est se
concentrer sur le fait de résoudre un
problème
le vrai pinpoint comme on dit dans la
silicon valley le caillou dans la
chaussure celui qui fait mal celui qui
fait saigner bon approche mais un peu
maso de l'entrepreneuriat mais juste
néanmoins l'inconvénient quand on dit ça
c'est que
personne ne vous explique vraiment ce
que c'est qu'un problème
c'est comme si vous disiez à quelqu'un
qui n'a jamais vu ce que c'est du feu
attention le feu ça brûle mais sans
jamais lui décrire à quoi ça ressemble
du feu il faut dire c'est pas facile de
décrire le feu c'est un truc qui bouge
beaucoup c'est rouge enfin danse pas
vraiment rouge c'est plutôt orange enfin
jaune
l'un des endroits bleus sur les bords
voire invisible enfin c'est pas clair et
ben un bon problème c'est pareil c'est
très difficile à caractériser
l'inconvénient c'est quand vous dites un
entrepreneur que ce qui est important
c'est pas son idée de solution c'est le
problème pas de souci il va inventer le
problème auquel répond sa solution
moi par exemple
il n'existe pas de plateforme qui
permettent simplement de découvrir du
contenu nouveau sur le web ça sonne bien
comme ça ne s'est pas un vrai problème
pour autant
souvent aussi ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
se rapproche à un problème très reste
dans la première boîte on voudrait aider
les fumeurs à arrêter de fumer on avait
développé un étui à paquet de clopes
connectés qui permettait de suivre sa
consommation de cigarettes et puis quand
on dépassait ses objectifs black hills
verrouillés
on nous a dit non mais concentre toi sur
le problème
pas de souci le problème les
gigantesques
il ya des millions de fumeurs la
majorité d'entre eux ont essayé
d'arrêter de fumer la plupart n'y arrive
pas aux rechutes donc le problème il est
vraiment critique
il a fallu un an pour que quelqu'un nous
fasse remarquer qu'il voyait pas le
rapport entre le problème dont on
parlait et la solution qu'on proposait
et il avait raison
contrairement à tout ce qui nous avait
fait gagner des concours de pitch
jusqu'à
donc dire aux gens de se concentrer sur
le problème c'est bien mais ça invite
les entrepreneurs à
inventer des problèmes mirage pour se
rassurer
et donc c'est pas un conseil suffisant
en soi mais
décrire ce que c'est un ce qui fait un
bon problème c'est vraiment pas facile
pourtant aujourd'hui quand je suis en
interview utilisateurs dans le cadre
d'un atelier de conception avec d'autres
innovateurs il ya un moment parfois ce
fameux aaa momments où le vrai problème
d'un coup tu le vois tu le reconnais tu
sais que parmi tout ce que tu as entendu
jusque là c'est sûr celui ci qu'il faut
le se concentrer c'est une évidence tu
reconnais le feu en fait
comment ça se fait
en fait c'est parce que ce mur est tombé
sur quelque chose d'un petit peu étrange
tu dis tiens c'est bizarre que ça
fonctionne comme ça c'est pas logique
c'est absurde c'est vraiment ça mais
c'est complètement absurde
et en fait c'est parce qu'à ce moment là
tu viens de tomber sur un paradoxe
et avec le recul après avoir accompagné
des centaines d'innovateur à lancer leur
projet que ce soit des start-up peur des
grands groupes d étudiants des
directeurs je me suis rendu compte que
les bons problème c'était des paradoxes
on va me dire super sympa ton tour de
passe-passe david tu as juste décalé la
question qu'est ce qui fait un bon
paradoxe alors ouais mais un bon
paradoxe est beaucoup plus facile à
caractériser parce qu'un paradoxe c'est
quelque chose qui à la fois évidemment
vrai est évidemment absurde et cette
contradiction là ça fait complètement
buggé ton cerveau à tel point qu'il
reconnaît vraiment très bien prenons un
exemple
quand on lance une fusée aujourd'hui on
jette des boosters de la fusée le
premier étage va à la mer alors que
c'est la partie la plus coûteuse de
toutes les fusées c'est des millions
voire des milliards
c'est absurde c'est vrai c'est paradoxal
c'est un bon problème et c'était le
point de départ évidemment de space x
un autre exemple il ya quelques années
c'était impossible à chaque fois qu'il y
avait une conférence de teck à san
francisco de trouver une place d'hôtel
une chambre d'hôtel tout était
complètement complet alors que à côté de
ça il y avait plein de chambre
d'appartements de maisons qui étaient
vite dans la ville
c'est vrai c'est absurde c'est paradoxal
c'est un bon problème et vous le savez
c'était le point de départ de rbi end
est en fait un paradoxe vous pouvez
souvent l'exprimer comme ça quelque
chose situation alors que besoin aux
besoins alors que situation mais ce qui
est important c'est que si vous lui en
parler à n'importe qui il faut que ce
soit évidemment vrai est évidemment
absurde
donc pour vous mettre sur la voie à la
recherche des paradoxes je vous
présentais deux grandes familles de
paradoxes le premier
c'est le paradoxe
invisible
le paradoxe invisible c'est quand vous
avez un problème que tout le monde a
mais dont personne se rend vraiment
compte dont personne c'est à ne plus
vraiment
par exemple en 2004 à la mi-temps de
super bowl justin timberlake arrache par
mégarde la robe de janet jackson et on
voit son sein devant la télévision
nationale là la planète entière commence
à chercher la vidéo du nipplegate
impossible de la trouver sur internet
alors que tout le monde le cherche
et vous le savez peut-être c'est comme
ça que les fondateurs de youtube ont eu
l'idée de lancer leur plateforme et donc
quand vous êtes face à ce genre de
paradoxe pour détecter plus tôt ce genre
de paradoxe qu'il faut c'est très très
bon en observation il faut réussir à
sortir un petit peu de sa posture
d'utilisateurs et se dire finalement
est ce qu'il n'ya pas des choses là qui
fonctionne pas comme elle devrait il
faut être très bonne observation très
bon en écoute posé beaucoup de questions
le deuxième type de grand paradoxe c'est
le paradoxe impossible cette fois-ci
tout le monde connaît bien le problème
il est critique il fait mal il coûte
cher il fait perdre du temps il est
récurrent et pourtant personne n'a
résolu il ya une douzaine d'années
c'était le plein essor des start up et
du e-commerce tout le monde voulait
réussir à monétiser son business en
ligne
mais pour réussir à mettre un simple
module de paiement par carte bleue sur
son site web il fallait rentrer dans un
process de six semaines avec une grande
banque auront réussir à intégrer du code
complètement complètement archaïque
faire travailler une dizaine de
personnes et en plus la banque prenait
des frais qui était faramineux à des
start up qui à ce moment là n'avaient
pas encore d'argent
et donc ça ce problème là ça a été le
point de départ de stripe que vous
utilisez peut-être tous les jours sans
le savoir d'ailleurs donc voilà de deux
grandes familles de paradoxe peut être
que vous en trouverez d'autres rappelez
moi si c'est le cas
mais que se passe-t-il quand vous avez
l'impression d'avoir trouvé un bon
problème mais pas vraiment de paradoxes
pour l'exprimer est ce qu'on peut se
dire bon c'est pas grave on esquive et
le conseil de david l'a peut-être mais
de mon expérience
c'est souvent vous allez trouver un
programme un problème qui est très vaste
juste mais il manque l'endroit où il est
suffisamment spécifique il manque
l'endroit où il fait suffisamment mal il
manque peut-être le sou problème un
petit peu plus précis si on prend
l'invention du portail électrique qu'on
peut contrôler avec une télécommande
pour ne pas avoir besoin de sortir de sa
voiture par exemple si j'essaie de
l'exprimer comme un paradoxe je dois
sortir de ma voiture pour vraiment par
taille alors que c'est pas pratique
c'est pas top
donc c'est pas un très bon paradoxe
maintenant si je vous dis que dans les
années 70 l'inventeur du portail
électrique il avait remarqué que les
mafiosos le moment où il risquait le
plus de se faire assassiner c'était
justement quand ils sortaient de leur
voiture et que c'était à ce moment là
qu'il est le plus de ça sinon
là le paradoxe il commence à être un
tout petit peu plus intéressant
et c'est vraiment comme ça que s'est
lancé il a réglé le problème pour la
mafia et puis ensuite son invention
s'est diffusé dans partout dans le monde
donc si vous êtes dans cette situation
vous avez l'impression d'avoir trouvé un
problème est que trouvez pas le paradoxe
essayé demandez-vous essaie de soulever
le capot chercher s'il n'est pas un sou
problème plus intéressant ou une cible
qui souffrent plus que les autres
peut-être que vous allez me dire oui
mais bon dans certains cas c'est pas le
problème qui est si critique que ça
c'est juste la solution qui est génial
qui est une super expérience et c'est ça
la vraie véritable innovation alors oui
vous avez raison ça arrive c'est une
réflexion un peu dangereux ça c'est une
pente glissante qui vous amène monter
une plateforme de découverte de contenu
qui sert à rien
mais si je pousse la réflexion jusqu'au
bout
si c'est pas vraiment un problème
pourquoi vous essayez de le résoudre
que ces petits problèmes en fait souvent
en général c'est pas des gros problème
c'est plutôt de l'ordre de la friction
trouvé c'est que les deux voitures c'est
pas pratique parfois on les perd je
préférerais que la voiture s'ouvrent
toutes seules ok d'accord
mais ces frictions est-ce qu'il faut
vraiment essayer de les résoudre parce
qu'il ya des frictions négative vraiment
embêtante mais aussi des frictions
positive prendre le temps de marcher
pour aller d'un point a à un point b ok
ça prend du temps mais ça m'a r ça me
permet de faire de l'exercice
faire à manger tous les soirs parfois
c'est un petit peu ennuyeux on a la
flemme mais d'un autre côté ça nous
permet de savoir de ce qu'on met dans
notre assiette déjà mais puis surtout
d'apprendre des recettes pouvoir les
transmettre par la suite et à force de
vouloir résoudre toutes ces frictions et
même ces frictions positive en fait on
perd la valeur ajoutée de ces frictions
et quand on lance une innovation on
s'intéresse beaucoup en général au
bénéfice concret ou aux problèmes qu'on
résout mais on s'intéresse rarement aux
problèmes qu'on a pu créer derrière et
aux bénéfices qu'on avait qu'on a perdu
les valeurs perdues de ces frictions
positive
et à force de supprimer des frictions
positive à force de se faire livrer de
la nourriture à domicile à force d'aller
en trottinette plutôt que de marcher
est-ce que in fine et on finirait pas
comme les humains dans wall-e qui sont
avec leurs fauteuils bull au volant et
peuvent commander leur soda xxl en un
clic sur leur petite plateforme
tout ça pour vous dire
si vous lancez une start-up si vous le
lancez une innovation
s'il vous plaît ne faites pas comme moi
prenez le temps surtout au début n'allez
pas trop vite prenez le temps de
chercher
le vrai problème chercher le paradoxe et
si vous le trouvez
demandez vous s'il faut vraiment le
résoudre merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]